[Music]
one of our writers Levi mcdougal who
happens to be Canadian has something he
wants to say he's never done this before
but he says it's important okay there
you go all right
at first Levi what are you wearing what
are you wearing it Canadian it's
December 2nd obviously I'm dressed for
the birthday of Canadian
singer-songwriter Nelly Furtado for
today is a national holiday in Canada ok
this this cannot be a real thing this
isn't real I'm telling you this is all
well-known Canadian tradition
wait so you could to face the Canadian
national flag but yes with the face of
Nelly Furtado a little Canadian humor
there yeah that's probably fire you
right now get what if you do you won't
get to hear me sing the frittata a
national anthem I'd rather not rather
not hear it very patate Nelly sacred
birthday Canada's pride on display
yeah
we love you more than the queen very ver
tarde
[Music]
in the future when you say you have
something to say on television I'm gonna
ask you what it is first okay sounds
great yeah I think that's gonna be the
new policy
[Music]
you